to sync your TripIt calendar you'll need
to get your unique calendar URL
here's how to do it
sign in to TripIt and go to your trips
tab
click calendar integration from the menu
select subscribe to calendar feed from
the pop-up and copy the URL it gives you
now sign into tungle me go to management
and then select synced in the menu
click add new calendar and contact sync
source select TripIt from the pop-up
name the calendar
and paste in the URL that you copied
from TripIt
click add source
your TripIt calendar is now synced
note that the telomy sync with TripIt is
read only
that means you'll be able to see your
trip at events in telewomi and your
availability will be updated as you add
new events to TripIt but tungomi will
not be able to add new events booked
through tungle me to your TripIt
calendar